spectacular spectacular spider worn
spiderman no way home footage trailer
and description coming oh oh i mean yes
definitely absolutely it should it's
already here it auto
let's see what info we got now updated
here let's see if any of my theories are
reflected in this video as well
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and of
course spider-man no way home i know a
lot of people are getting really
impatient for that spider-man no way
home trailer you owe me in fact i
started the other day asking if at this
point we even really need the spider-man
no way home trailer of course i think we
do but i was just curious to hear what
everybody else thought and i see
everybody's frustration but hopefully
today's news will put that at ease a
tiny bit i got a question are there
people actually walking around just
going man i just wondering where is that
focus on anything like that
work done i can't make love to my wife
my marriage is crumbling because it says
damn trailer trailer out of my head
sony's ruining my life and you're either
going to enjoy this news or kind of
think that sony is trolling a little bit
more but i promise you today's news is a
good thing and to keep up to date on the
spider-man news be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos
alright so if you haven't heard sony
pictures is attending cinemacon this
year and if you have heard this news you
may not have heard everything that's
going along with it so stick with me
here so sony pictures is actually
opening up cinemacon on opening night oh
they're opening it august 23rd so in a
couple of weeks from now and it starts
at 9 00 pm eastern time now sony has
three
hours they have a three three-hour
presentation where they're said to show
all of their upcoming films not the
whole films obviously but parts or clips
or whatever they want to put together to
show the audience at cinemacon some
executive just gonna walk on stage go
here
it's fine put it on loop for three hours
you guys don't care about any of our
other movies no one bothered to watch
escape room two so here's spider-man no
way home trailer three hours i really
think we were gonna package that trailer
with that move they actually did this
for spider-man fire from home before the
trailer 4 far from home came out at ccxp
tom holland and jake gyllenhaal attended
and they showed the actual trailer there
before it came out to the public they
literally showed it at a comic con ccxp
stands for the comic con experience sony
showed it at their panel before anybody
in the world saw it and unfortunately
but also kind of fortunately it looks
like that's what we're about to see
they're either going to show an actual
trailer or footage however unfortunately
this is probably not going to be
released to the public it's going to be
up to somebody to leak it if the public
is going to see it some hero out there
of recording devices at all are going to
be allowed inside of the session and all
phones are going to have to be turned
off and i actually really wouldn't be
surprised if they made them do more like
put their phones in lockers or something
like that check their [ __ ]
at the same time this isn't going to be
like marvel studios showing something
and then at the same time it pops up on
youtube unfortunately disney has already
confirmed that sony is the one handling
all of the trailer releases and the
marketing disney is in the loop and
aware of everything that they're going
to do and when they're going to do it
but sony is handling everything it's up
to them and this was confirmed by
disney's president of marketing disney's
president marketing is like stop calling
guys
don't email me anymore yeah everybody in
the department's just like tell them
anything just blame it on sodium sodium
sodium make sodium in the back i already
got a lawsuit to deal with there is some
good news to this because even though
people can't show footage they can still
talk about what they saw even though
they're forcing their cameras off
just as good
i want to experience the trailer going
out and talking about what they saw and
of course there are probably going to be
some very loyal spider-man fans out
there who probably can't wait to go to
the internet and share what they saw so
despite what happens if any type of
footage is shown for spider-man no way
home we are going to hear about that
footage and know what it is on august
23rd i almost hope it actually is
footage and not the actual trailer and
here's why i've said this at kind of the
end of some of my videos and i know the
majority of people don't watch all the
way till the end so i'll say it now
personally heard from one of my sources
that the very first teaser trailer for
spiderman no way home is not going to
contain the other spiderman i was
specifically told that when the
marketing campaigns do start for
spiderman no way home they aren't going
to start marketing the other two
spiderman until about either halfway or
two thirds into the campaign that means
the teaser trailer is not going to have
them and that means probably the first
trailer that we get isn't going to have
them either however i am specifically
talking about the other two spider-man
so that doesn't mean that we can't see
alfred molina's doggock show up it
doesn't mean that we won't see jamie
foxx's electro i definitely think we'll
see signs of the multiverse spider verse
but they're still going to try and build
up hype and the way you do that is you
start with a teaser tease a little bit
then do a full-on trailer kind of
explaining what the story is and then
you reveal the other two so leading into
december theoretically we're gonna get a
a teaser trailer like three months
before an official trailer and that is
second trailer
knowing sony trailers three through
eight
show as much footage as possible that's
a lot of trailers
in the span of three months for one
movie uh-huh and knowing us we're not
gonna cover any of it no no maybe one
maybe one and then call it quits just
stay with the leaks only interested in
the lead-up to the trailer and nothing
else now in terms of when are we
actually going to see the trailer the
general public when is it going to go on
youtube or on tv we don't really have an
exact time frame right now but daniel
rpk at one point in time said that we
would have to have another shanghi
trailer and another eternals trailer
before getting spider-man well we've had
that other shanxi trailer and the other
day he actually tweeted out stating that
he thinks that it will be with either
shang qi or venom 2. and venom 2
actually makes a lot of sense because
again that is coming from sony and it
actually seems like right now his
marketing priority is venom 2 which
makes sense because it is coming out
first and they just released their full
trailer for the movie last week actually
not even it was only five days ago it
was this week which means the full
trailer released literally less than two
months before the movie is actually
coming out which means they released the
teaser trailer four months before the
actual movie is coming out so we can
assume that they're going to follow
somewhat of a similar pattern for
spider-man no way home we'll say that
does one pretty good credence to the
argument
and i mean especially during the past
year and a half two years it seems like
the marketing windows have gotten
smaller yeah so it's not so odd no i
mean it's par for the course of what the
recent history has been there is always
the possibility that they could delay
spider-man no way home they could delay
its release date obviously nobody wants
this but with all the different variants
of kobit and yes i did use variant
intentionally
it seems like studios are kind of
freaking out again that people won't go
to theaters because venom and spider-man
no way home aren't going to be released
anywhere else but in the theaters these
are theatrical releases only so there is
that possibility that spider-man no way
home could be delayed especially if you
consider the fact that they're actually
doing reshoots right now for the film
now i hope it's not it's pretty tight
it's not but if they didn't show a
trailer at cinemacon they could actually
reveal a new release date so keep that
in mind and be prepared for that because
that could happen who wouldn't be
totally surprised the other spider-man
movies come out in the summer june july
and then the last time they should they
debuted something debuted with the the
ladies
the last time they debuted a trailer
decided far from home that it was also
summer everything's a mess the biggest
possibility is that maybe they're still
unsure of the release date and maybe
that's contributing to this but i'm
thinking shang chi might have something
to do with it if shang chi does well
they're sticking to that release date
and that's the first one out of the
marvel or disney's movies that will be
solely theatrical release right that's
the only one i'm pretty sure no dual
release strategy suicide squad is not
any of them but it's not doing well to
box ups right now
so yeah what i understand that's just a
theatrical and yeah and we got you know
the delta
airlines to worry about they keep
falling out of the sky
dangerous out there a lot of people got
airplanes crashing on their houses yeah
it's an epidemic
man
all those frat kids massacres i follow
the news overall good news because
whatever they show at cinemacon we are
going to hear about we are going to get
a full description of so even though i
am 100 convinced that the public is not
going to see whatever footage or trailer
for spiderman no way home that is going
to be shown at cinemacon i am convinced
that we will be getting an exact
description of what they saw because
this happened with spider-man far from
home i hope at cc xp all they do is an
old man comes out whips out a piece of
paper and gives us the trailer
description
it's so secret we can't even show it
here
so i'm just going to read off the shot
list and who knows if marvel studios
does do their own panel we could get a
description for shang chi the eternals
miss marvel hawkeye moon knight all of
their upcoming stuff we could learn a
great deal more about but of course i
know that everybody at this point is
pretty much just concerned about that
spider-man no way home trailer which i
completely understand i want that
hawkeye footage
will come out not too long after the
footage is shown at cinemacon but keep
an eye out the 23rd for more information
about whatever they show at cinemacon
because we are going to find out then so
be sure to subscribe and hit the
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the videos and you can follow
me on twitter and instagram because i
always do live updates on there let me
know your thoughts on the video in the
comment down below don't forget the like
i thought you did a good video anyways
thank you so much for watching your
coverage of this topic was thorough and
informative all right guys well when's
that trailer coming in when do you think
it's coming
your thoughts down below
hey subscribe to warren's channel he's a
great guy with a huge ass
hit that like button
and yo we'll catch you guys soon but not
before we do a
sarah campbell sarah does not like comic
book movies all that much or anything
really with a built-in franchise and she
popped into our suicide squad live
stream spoiler talk and when she hadn't
even seen the movie
but you know we need supporters like
that more like sarah people who just
show up to watch our videos and get
things room for them whether or not
they're interested in the majority of
what we cover you can't ask for a better
supporter someone who doesn't watch most
of your videos or even you know pledges
at a reasonably high tier at our patreon
and doesn't even watch most of those but
likes us for some reason
you need to know more people like sarah
sarah you're good people you're good
people sarah that's why they named the
soup after you oh dude
that's comforting sarah's home style
sarah's soup
i love a good can of sarah
multinational conglomerate sarah's soup
[Music]